[Music]
where are you from
chicago
no
where are you really from
the south side of chicago
no like
like like what are you
for years
i couldn't explain why incidents like
this made me feel so uncomfortable
you speak such good english
you must be good at math
your people's food is so spicy
innocuous
on the surface
but when repeated 10
20
50 times
i would start to get annoyed
but
these were just curious people with good
intentions right what right did i have
to be annoyed
it wasn't until i was in college
that i realized what i was experiencing
were racial microaggressions
psychologist gerald wing sue
defines microaggressions as brief
everyday exchanges that send denigrating
messages to certain individuals based on
their group membership
while they can be the product of
environmental or behavioral slights
most of the time
they are unintentional
and they happen all the time
in fact in a recent survey that i sent
out to my gsb classmates 77
of respondents identified as having been
the victim of a microaggression
so why do we care well take this example
when a young woman repeatedly hears
you have a great shot at that promotion
because they need a female on their
leadership team
she starts to feel like she doesn't
deserve to be there
based on her own merits alone
she starts to feel like she doesn't
belong
think that was too extreme of an example
take my opening question
no where are you really from
implies that
chicago cannot be a valid answer
i cannot be american
i must be a foreigner i cannot claim to
be from the place that i'm from
because of how i look
and i perpetually don't belong
now
the purpose of my talk today is not to
play the victim or
to even fantasize about a perfect world
where there are no microaggressions that
would be unrealistic because of all of
the unique backgrounds experiences and
implicit biases that everybody on this
earth carries with us me included
instead
i want to recognize
that these tiny snubs exist
all of us commit them and that's going
to happen
while our intent is not necessarily
malicious
different comments land with different
people in different ways
and i'm here
to bring awareness to that fact of life
and more importantly
to tell you what i've learned we can do
if and when
we find ourselves on either end of a
microaggression
a couple years ago i had a boss
casually throw me the advice to act more
like the men in the room
i was stunned
i had no words to express how i was
feeling
so i just said okay
and walked back to my desk
six months passed
and i heard those words haunting me
every single day
you should act more like a man
being a woman is not good enough
my sense of self-worth
my confidence and my productivity took a
hit
as i desperately tried to figure out how
to make sense of that comment
how could we have avoided this situation
let's turn to the receiving end there
are three things that you can do when
you find yourself the recipient of a
microaggression
first
and most importantly
prioritize yourself
there are situations where it doesn't
make sense to respond if i had gotten
this comment from a stranger i'd never
see again or
perhaps if my safety could have been
compromised if i did respond i would
give myself the permission to not say
anything
and i know
that it's unfair that the emotional
burden of whether or not to respond
falls on the recipient
but the more comfortable we get
with drawing boundaries and predicting
the implications to our lives if we do
not respond
the easier it gets
second
if you're in a place too
ask clarifying questions
i could have simply asked my boss
what exactly do you mean by that
he likely would have
said something about how i should be
more confident or how i should be more
aggressive with my good opinions
no mal intent
great
and third
if you have the emotional bandwidth too
state how the comment
impacted you
in one of the gsb's flagship classes on
interpersonal dynamics we always talk
about how
i cannot assume your intent since that's
something only you know
and that you
cannot assume the impact that your words
have on me since that's something only i
know
in the class
we call these assumptions crossing the
net
in the case of a microaggression
if it is productive to state how the
comment made you feel
it can help the perpetrator learn and
perhaps change their behavior for next
time
in my example
i could have simply told my boss
when you tell me to act like a man
i feel frustrated and dejected
because i can never be enough due to who
i am
i did eventually confront my boss and
tell him this and i remember he looked
shocked
he fumbled and
admitted that he hadn't realized that's
how i had taken it and that his intent
was just to be helpful
he did apologize for the effect that his
advice had on me
and i immediately felt like a part of
the team again
let's quickly turn
to the giving end
a couple years ago i was joking with my
friends in seattle about our experiences
living there when my friend made a
comment about the lack of diversity
there to which i said
what do you care you're just a straight
white man
i watched his face fall
and immediately knew
that i had crossed a line that i hadn't
meant to
being the perpetrator of
more than a few of these kinds of
careless comments has taught me three
things that you can do
when you find that you've just committed
a microaggression
first
accept the other person's truth
if they tell you
how you made them feel
don't cross the net
trust their reality and use it to inform
how you show up next time
which leads me to number two
be open to change and learn from the
experience
not only can that help you do better
next time
but that can help you become a better
ally if you see similar microaggressions
being committed by others
and third
if you find yourself feeling guilty
remember
we are only human
everybody makes mistakes
microaggressions are largely
unintentional and their impact is not
even uniform across members of the same
group
different comments land with different
people in different ways and while it's
more than okay to be curious about where
i'm from
the decision to reject my truth
turns ignorance into malice
and small pinches
into a bruise
it would be naive
to think that we can completely rid the
world of microaggressions but we can
react to them in a more productive way
by strengthening our muscles of asking
the questions and trusting the responses
it is my hope
that we are all better equipped
to handle this world's inevitable
imperfect situations with greater
empathy and trust
so that nobody feels like they don't
belong
thank you
[Music]